when they were about to face down all
manner of things worse than anyone's
deepest darkest nightmares alex and the
rest of his team did what they could to
keep their spirits up there was an old
song they used to hum whenever heading
on missions the low sound of that tune
giving them just a marginal boost to
their morale it never did all that much
to numb the sense of impending doom the
team all collectively felt but it was
better than sitting in a transport unit
in silence letting the dread get to them
even though it had been a while since
mobile task force epsilon had been
dispatched on their current assignment
and they all had hummed it together as
they shipped out alex found himself
trying to remember the words to that old
song
smile through your fear and sorrow then
maybe tomorrow you'll see the sun come
shining through it was pretty hard for
alex to keep a smile on his face after
losing so many of his teammates and
seeing what the grinner had done to them
the trail had gone cold again much to
the disdain of the team's commanding
officer receiving a number of new
sightings and witness reports the scp
foundation had sent the remaining
members of mtf epsilon also known under
the code name tierfing black out on
another hunt for scp-4910
the creature had been at large for years
now with every attempt the foundation
had made to capture it ending in grisly
gut-churning failure 57 separate times
they had sent their personnel after this
anomaly on the loose and not all of them
had come back although alex often found
himself thinking of the ones that had
returned and seeing photos of how they
had changed in the after-action reports
not to mention the bodies those that
made it back ended up looking virtually
unrecognizable as human beings after
having seen what happened to them maybe
it was better not to know what gruesome
fate had befallen the ones who were
still missing an action he told himself
keeping that train of thought private
tracking scp-4910 brought its own
plethora of issues naturally or the
foundation would have secured it by now
the creature had some way of interfering
with recording devices rendering them
completely useless and of course that
meant that tirfing black had little to
no clue what the monster actually looked
like given that it disrupted any and all
recording equipment including cameras
and audio devices the task force's hands
were somewhat tied it forced alex and
his teammates to try and locate it
through more old-fashioned means
following up on eyewitness reports a lot
of which led them to a dead end every
now and then however one of these
sightings would prove to be genuine the
quickest way to tell was usually if a
person living near the place where a
report came in from had gone missing
lately civilians were
scp-4910's main source of food and a
recent disappearance in the area paired
with the sighting of something large and
four-legged usually meant that the beast
had come out of hiding to feed again
alright listen up team commanding
officer sawyer announced with the level
of militaristic speed and discipline
expected of them by the foundation alex
and the other members of the mobile task
force quickly filed out of the transport
and fell in ready and waiting to receive
their orders now you all know the reason
why we're here sawyer strode back and
forth arms behind his back as he
addressed what was left of his unit
three operatives not including himself
even so it is imperative you don't
forget it either so these are the facts
today the anomaly designated as
scp-4910 is still running wild but if we
have anything to say about it then that
sucker won't be running for much longer
the three troops gave a quick chant in
agreement although alex kept quiet just
mouthing along he wasn't exactly sure
that they would actually ever catch up
to the grinner so little footage of the
monster even existed meaning the team
still had little to no clue what this
thing was or if they were even equipped
to fight it and then again a huge part
of him didn't want to ever find scp-4910
knowing what it had done to the fallen
former members of mobile task force
epsilon so here's the latest commander
sawyer continued silencing the team
approximately 12 hours ago we received a
message from one of the foundation's
field operatives this agent has been in
deep cover living in a nearby town for a
number of years as he spoke the
commanding officer gestured down the
high ridge that they had landed on far
below sitting in the center of a huge
dip in the earth was a small township
there was barely enough room for more
than a few hundred people at most all
around this small urban center bordering
the entire town in an almost perfect
circle was a dense forest it was ideal
cover for the monster and alex could see
on his teammates faces that they all
knew it too with them in the town there
was no way they could cover every
possible avenue of approach this
operative is he the one that called in
the eyewitness report one of the team
warren piped up and asked that is
correct agent warren sawyer confirmed
that agent has agreed to meet us at a
rendezvous a few clicks north of here
the four of us will circumnavigate the
town stick to the cover of these woods
as we head out to make contact with him
from there he'll guide us to where the
creature was sighted the team gave
little response just a few low murmurs
expressing their collective apprehension
in a strange way alex found it
comforting that at the very least he
wasn't the only one having some serious
reservations about potentially coming
face to face with scp-4910
now boys
their commander's side
i get it all of us have been trying to
catch this freak for a long while and
we've lost a lot of good people from our
unit along the way but we are turfing
black you hear me you all know what that
name means tirfing as the sword from
norse mythology cursed to kill every
time it was drawn and that's us that is
exactly what we are gonna do when we
finally find this monster for all our
fallen brothers and sisters by the time
we're done with it the grinner will be
smiling out from the other side of its
ugly face now let's move out double time
with a half-hearted cheer the squad
prepared to start their hike through the
force that encircled the town the four
survivors of mobile task force epsilon
fanned out keeping close enough to see
and hear each other but not too close
that they were clustered together the
more they huddled up the easier it would
be to take them out if the grinner was
able to get the jump on them although he
should have been keeping his eyes
forward looking out for any tracks the
creature might have left alex couldn't
help checking over his shoulder the sun
was getting lower and lower in the sky
the day rapidly turning to night before
long their visibility would be
compromised severely limited by the lack
of natural light it was then he looked
to his fellow team members warren and
jones besides alex himself and the
squad's commander they were the only
turfing black operatives left warren had
always been the more brash and outspoken
of the group willing to stand up and
question the orders of commanding
officer sawyer alex could tell warren
was having the same worries about this
plan as he was the thick treeline gave
them plenty of cover but could also
easily work to the monster's advantage
allowing it to sneak up and get the drop
on the team with relative ease but both
alex and warren also knew that if the
mtf was pushed back towards the town
they would be trapped like fish in a
barrel just waiting to be picked off by
scp-4910
jones was walking slightly ahead of the
others his gaze rapidly scanning back
and forth across the forest before them
he was the team's most accomplished
tracker meaning he was always on the
lookout for anything that could give
them a better idea as to where the
grinner was heading or if it was nearby
from scratches on tree bark to series of
inhuman unnatural footprints belonging
to a large quadruped beast and of course
trails of blood or bodies if there was a
sign jones would find it much like alex
the other two operatives had become more
than a little jaded with their ongoing
hunt for the elusive entity but on top
of that not either one of them would
admit it to the others they were scared
of it too the things this creature were
capable of were enough to make anyone
think twice about wanting to find it as
much to quell his own fear and sorrow as
well as that of his teammates alex
started humming the tune to smile just
loud enough for them to hear but quiet
enough he hoped to not draw any unwanted
attention it was already dark by the
time tirfing black was beginning to
approach the coordinates where they had
arranged to meet the foundation agent
commander sawyer had given his troops a
silent hand signal and all of them had
lowered their night vision goggles
affixed to their helmets through the
fuzzy green hue of the optics jones was
the first to spot a figure leaning
against a tree waiting for them in the
distance
sir you whispered to sawyer catching his
attention and then making a gesture
towards the vaguely human shape in the
shadows ahead of them looking to where
jones had pointed alex and warren could
see the agent waiting for them following
their commander's lead they paced
steadily towards the undercover
operative it was only as they stepped
closer that they realized he wasn't
moving agent manning sawyer called out
to him trying to keep his voice as
hushed and low as possible no response
manning was still propped up against the
tree trunk the team were a few feet from
him now while the commander stepped up
to the agent and turned him around by
his shoulder only to recoil at what he
saw manning's eyes were open but
remained unblinking and lifeless but
that was far from the worst thing that
had happened to his face a huge
disproportionate grin had stretched his
mouth wider than was natural masses of
jagged uneven teeth had taken root
pushing from under his tongue and the
roof of his mouth filling his airways
with thick clusters of yellowy white
enamel there were so many new teeth
sprouting from manning's face that new
fixed and unsettling smiles had started
to form splitting open his cheeks back
back sawyer told his men in an urgent
hushed whisper remember boys we don't
know how contagious this thing is given
they had never seen it in the flesh that
was true
all previous failed attempts at bringing
in scp-4910 had ended with victims
displaying similar signs of some unknown
anomalous infection whatever it was it
seemed to have spread from the creature
itself causing human beings to
overproduce masses of teeth this started
with new clusters of dentins painfully
tearing through the mouth until the
victim could no longer speak or breathe
properly if given enough time the teeth
would begin forming elsewhere on the
body below the neck in places they
shouldn't be the lucky ones not that
there were many of them had managed to
get themselves medical attention soon
after they had been exposed within an
hour maybe two at best of an encounter
with scp-4910
there was still a chance of saving one
of its victims through intensive dental
surgery but three or four hours
afterward and it would already be too
late hearing the distant snap of a twig
jones turned with his weapon raised arms
locked in a combat ready stance possible
contact he declared aiming his gun into
the deep shadowy forest matching his
bearing and targeting the same area
sawyer gave a hand signal to alex and
warren urging them to lock and load
lifting their rifles they covered the
opposite direction just in case someone
or something came dashing out of the
forest at them from the other direction
for a few moments everything was still
although certainly not calm in the last
part feeling a beat of sweat crawled
down the back of his neck alex lifted a
hand to wipe his face clean the only
sound being the low panting breaths of
the four mtf agents that was when he saw
a shadow move just ahead of him darting
between the trees before vanishing from
the view of his optics once again
it was at least the size of a horse far
bigger than alex had expected and able
to move around astonishingly fast on its
four legs movement this side he
announced alerting his teammates it's
toying with us sawyer muttered with
respect how is that possible sir warren
asked it's an animal isn't it it's a
hunter jones replied we need to move our
visibility is no good with all these
trees around the commander whispered on
my mark we make our way towards the town
but sir we'll be sitting ducks down
there he can flank us from any side
warren argued we're better off down
there at least we have street lights to
help see it coming alex interjected
mainly just making an excuse to get as
far away from the encroaching entity as
possible this isn't up for discussion
sawyer said taking command head for the
town that's an order on my account three
two contact jones shouted the deafening
noise and blinding muzzle flash of his
weapon firing quickly followed as he
sprayed bullets wildly at the shape that
was barreling through the forest towards
the team alex turned to see what was
happening only for sawyer to yell at the
top of his voice almost drowned out by
the gunfire go and get out of here now
obeying his orders alex turned his heels
and sprinted towards the low orange
light of the nearby town just visible at
the edge of the tree line warren was
next to him matching his speed their
heavy tactical gear that was strapped to
their bodies jostling back and forth
each time one foot came down on the
forest floor glancing back over his
shoulder alex saw jones had cease fire
and was running up behind them further
back was sawyer with the grinner bearing
down on him the commanding officer of
terrafing black had his weapon raised
fingers squeezing down on the trigger
every round he fired illuminated part of
the forest for a split second alex
couldn't make out the creature in any
great detail not while also running
further and further away increasing his
distance from it all he could make out
from this far was a fleshy quadrupedal
mass galloping straight for sawyer he
was yelling to get
scp-4910's attention the sound of his
war cries carrying over the night air as
the three mtf agents broke through the
tree line and reached the edge of the
forest their commander's shouts quickly
turned into screams of intense pain and
unspeakable horror and then
fell silent alex wasn't sure if the
creature had attacked and eaten him or
caused more of those unnatural teeth to
fill sawyer's mouth blocking his screams
permanently reaching the town every road
was completely deserted gently lit by
the dim glow of orange street lights
tiny rural stores and independent
businesses had their doors bolted tight
rolled down shutters locked up for the
night meaning hiding in one of the
buildings wasn't an option panting alex
leaned over and put his hands on his
knees trying desperately to catch his
breath
now what warren asked the terror in his
voice impossible to miss
nothing's gonna be here any second we
need to get away from here as fast as we
can and then send word to the foundation
alex answered speaking between deep
breathless wheezes
tell them we need backup this thing is
too dangerous for only three of us to
take on there may not be enough time for
that jones chimed in standing a few
paces away from the others he had been
staring down the long stretch of the
street they had stopped at frozen to the
spot barely moving a muscle both alex
and warren turned to look in the same
direction and there it was only a few
feet away under the light of a street
lamp it was almost like
scp-4910 was waiting for them to catch
their breath intelligent enough to know
its hunt wasn't yet over alex having now
finally gotten a better look at the
monster instantly wished he hadn't it
made him feel sick like there was a lump
lodged in the back of his throat the
grinner stood atop four pink sinnohy
legs its body just a formless mass of
pure musculature that looked like it had
been sculpted out of the same tissue
that human gums are made from it lacked
a neck instead having a pair of massive
jaws poking out between its front
shoulders a dark marble-like eye on
either side of its head as
cp-4910's wide almost crocodilian jaws
parted showing off what had earned it
the ironic nickname of the grinner it
presented a gaping maw of crooked uneven
teeth with more clusters of enamel
protruding from its back elbows and head
these teeth even formed the hooves it
walked on at this distance it was hard
to tell if the sickening yellow coloring
of the teeth was purely because of the
street lights or that they had been
stained and covered in plaque alex tried
to contain a cough in his throat his
stomach feeling like it was folding over
itself at the sickening site of scp-4910
he started spluttering wondering if he
was about to vomit given the lingering
feeling at the back of his throat like
the sensation one gets when something is
forcing its way up the esophagus but it
was lodged the feeling wasn't coming up
and out of alex's throat it was stuck
there by now he was wheezing desperately
trying to breathe through relentless
coughs jones kept his eyes on the
creature he was pacing slowly towards
them now keeping a distance but moving
like a lion encircling its prey warren
turned and kneeled down to alex slapping
him hard on the back trying to help him
cough up whatever he was practically
choking on alex's eyes started going
misty watering up as he gasped for air
still feeling that lingering feeling of
being held right at the edge of being
sick in a final act of desperation he
jammed his fingers down his throat
trying to dislodge or dispel whatever
was making him gag that's when he felt
it a cluster of little solid pieces
embedded in the roof of his mouth
teeth that hadn't been there before
hadn't grown naturally but had just
sprung out of his flesh and more were
growing pain filled his mouth spreading
over alex's entire face as new jagged
teeth came bursting through his gum line
overlapping with his natural set tearing
his jaw into a wide crooked grin looking
up through his tear-filled eyes he could
see the same uneven smile on the face of
the grinner as
scp-4910 began dashing towards its next
prey
now go and check out
scp-323 the wendigo skull and scp-2086
man eating bus if you dare to learn more
about even more malicious monstrosities
carnivorous creatures and atrocious
anomalies that all seek to do harm to
humans